bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got jeremy
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
absolutely thanks man for sure uh let's
just jump right into it uh give us a
refresher on usd
coin what is it and how does it work
yeah absolutely so
usdc is something that um we started
working on in in
2017 and then launched in 2018
um and uh you know usdc was sort of
envisioned
to be what i like to call like a
protocol layer for
money on the internet and and when i
think about money obviously there's like
crypto money like bitcoin
and ether and then you have sort of
quote unquote traditional money which is
essentially like liabilities of a
central bank
so how can we take like liabilities with
a central bank represent those as a
digital currency
and then let them transact in the same
way that you can transact other
cryptocurrencies through a protocol
for kind of payment and settlement on on
a blockchain so
usdc very much conceived of that and and
ultimately with the idea that it could
be
a protocol that lots of people could
connect to anyone could implement
whether you're you know consumer product
a business you know a wallet
what have you um but when we designed it
we wanted it to be something that
was regulated um because if people are
going to really
depend on this as a dollar
you know a dollar a sort of a digital
currency dollar
it it needs to have the assurances of
being you know issued by a regulated
financial institution
have you know the sort of compliance and
security and audit
and all the things that kind of go along
with that so that people understand that
for every dollar that is issued in a
digital token that
those are reserved and that there's
oversight of that there's
you know global accounting firms there's
examiners regulators
there's banks that are regulated that
look at and manage those reserves so
it's sort of a
you know it's it is a trusted model um
it's not fully a trustless model but
it's a trusted model for
dollar digital currency so you know
essentially a
a person or a business a person could uh
or a business can say go
to a circle open an account and
essentially convert
from you know a bank transfer into usdc
they can have usdc issued and they can
also redeem
um and we also you know work really
closely with coinbase as
as a critical um partner in this and so
you can also kind of go to coinbase and
create and redeem usdc uh as well so
it's um you know that's what ucc is it's
grown enormously it's
it's um you know like a year ago it's
like 500 million in circulation today
there's 13.2 billion
in circulation um so growing at a pretty
amazing rate and
thousands of companies kind of
supporting and implementing it um today
where's all the growth coming from like
what why has it grown so quickly
yeah i mean we really started to see
this tremendous growth
really dating back to right around kind
of
when the pandemic hit in asia you know
first started hitting in asia last year
and then it picked up as the pandemic
spread and i think part of this was just
in general
a uh a a shift into digital currency
that started to take place
um both uh you know as a store of value
as an as a as a form of investment
capital
and and we saw you know demand globally
so we saw demand for these sort of
dollar digital currency units from latin
america africa
asia other other places so just in
general that started to grow
as digital asset markets themselves have
grown usdc has sort of become synonymous
with being sort of the dollar market
infrastructure uh
sort of a trusted liquid redeemable
dollar market infrastructure
for for that space and so just in line
with the growth in
digital asset markets and then really
notably um
you know we we very early on even back
in 2018 when we were launching this we
focused a lot of energy on
working with emerging projects that were
building decentralized finance and d5
protocols
and um started to see traction with
those in 2019 and then
you know just as those have taken off
you know over the last year
uscc has sort of grown significantly
alongside it so when you look at the
compounds and the aves and the unit
swaps and
those kinds of platforms usdc plays a
huge role in those
um as well so we've grown with that and
then the last piece is basically
as this you know as the occ grows in
circulation and more and more
individuals or businesses
hold it they're basically seeing that
has really incredible utility value you
know you can settle a transaction
you know in minutes with settlement
finality i mean a lot of the same
assurances that you get from like a
bitcoin transaction you get with a
dollar transaction and
people who understand like the power of
cryptocurrency or like this is just a
better way to settle
transactions and so we're seeing just a
lot of growth in
various payments and settlement use
cases even you know recently
visa itself um you know building usdc
natively into visa's core network as
a currency as a settlement rail uh for
for uh for their network which is really
amazing um so
it's sort of moving into these other
spaces and and obviously that's a big
part of the vision for where it goes
one of the most popular questions that i
get whenever i bring up
usdc is just how the hell does circle
make money explain kind of the way that
you interact with this
uh the work you guys do obviously to
support it but also how you make money
yeah so i mean circle has a few
different
um revenue streams basically so
obviously we kind of operate the uscc
market infrastructure
and we we basically provide that almost
like a public utility
and so like you know a business an
institution can enroll in a circle
account
um we only uh uh service businesses
directly
um and can you know at you know at no
cost basically create and redeem usdc
we administer it we run it etc and um
and obviously as as part of that as a
regulated um
financial services company we also
manage those reserves
that 13.2 billion in reserves and so
there is some
revenue that that comes from that and
then the second is
is you know we we launched really
starting last spring
a whole family of um kind of transaction
and treasury infrastructure services
that were built up around it so
basically providing
all the apis that a company would need
to connect
the existing bank networks like you know
bank transfers wire transfers
credit cards debit cards and wire that
right into
usdc settlement the infrastructure for
you know wallets and custody and storage
um for people who want to you know use
that within their own treasury operation
whether it's a b2b or b2c product and
that kind of collection of
platform services is a is a very big
revenue driver for the company
as you know lots and lots of companies
are building on this
and they essentially need that kind of
um financial infrastructure for their
own
products and services so so that's a
that's a big revenue uh
driver for us and um and then yeah we
have some new revenue streams we're
launching but but we also
uh operate the largest um equity
crowdfunding platform in the united
states which is seed invest
uh which is a pretty significant revenue
driver for us too
got it talk a little bit more about kind
of the treasury management
uh in terms of your guys end so a lot of
people know
that there's other stable coins where
they basically take the reserves and
uh they generate yield or revenue from
it uh there's a whole bunch of
speculation
around just how much risk is taken there
versus
uh some of the stable coins versus
others like how do you think about
uh generating that yield are there
specific things that you guys do both
from a risk mitigation standpoint and
also a revenue generation
uh view well so i i'm kind of breaking
into into two pieces
the first is you know um circle is
is regulated and supervised by uh you
know state banking
uh regulators and we we have a very
strict uh what i call kind of regulatory
perimeter
for the permissible investments um
behind
electronic money behind kind of stored
electronic stored value electronic money
so and that's supervised and examined by
by examiners
um and there's there's also occ
regulations that came into uh
you know guidelines that came out last
year as well that has to do with you
know if if you are in fact say a reserve
bank
uh that is providing reserve capacity to
a stable private stable coin issuer
you know again the the kind of
fundamental um kind of
uh examination requirements of that so
it's pretty tightly bounded
um and and uh and we obviously have you
know
large global accounting firms attesting
to
the fact that we're you know meeting all
of our obligations there as well so
it's pretty narrow like we can't go out
and you know take risk basically you
know
we you know it is pretty narrow on the
other hand
what's happening is there's these
incredibly fast growing
um lending markets in usdc itself and so
a lot of the yield generation is
essentially
blockchain mediated borrowing and
lending markets
some of those are done through
centralized institutions like crypto
prime brokerage firms
and some of that is done through
decentralized markets like you know
compound protocol ave protocol things
like that
those those markets where there are
borrowers and lenders of usdc are
are you know really really meaningful
and and that's where you know we um
we have a product our high yield digital
dollar accounts for businesses
uh that's imminently going to become
available and will allow a corporation
their own working capital their own
treasury to kind of allocate into usdc
yield
which is really providing a very simple
regulated secured
uh environment to access that kind of
market explain a little bit more in
those markets whether they're kind of
the centralized or decentralized
versions why are people
borrowing and then what are they doing
with the usdc once they borrow
yeah i mean so you have a wide range of
use cases there obviously
you know you're familiar with like the
block files of the world so people are
are borrowing usdc uh sometimes because
they
they they don't want to sell their
bitcoin but they want to buy a car
or they don't want to sell their bitcoin
and they want to put a down payment on a
house or
you know so it's essentially people who
are borrowing against other crypto
assets that they
have uh because they they believe that
that's um
you know a good you know a good strategy
um so so that's yeah that's one and that
and that exists at the
retail and institutional level obviously
around the market
you also have a phenomenon of you know i
think in general
um and this is proven to be a
pretty sound strategy over the past 10
years but a lot of
a lot of folks that are in the digital
asset space are fundamentally
if not entirely structurally long things
like bitcoin
um and and again that's that's proven to
be a pretty good strategy
over over 10 years it's probably you
know
in my view again this is not investment
advice my view is that i think it's
probably a pretty good strategy over the
next 10 years
uh and and so um you know basically
people are borrowing usdc
um because they're structurally long btc
and they want to be able to
continue to invest and trade um and so
that's
a big borrower a big driver of borrowing
demand but it's it's evolving so we're
seeing
again this gets into like uscc is
becoming
more of a payment and settlement medium
people want to utilize it as a working
capital medium
so for example you're seeing uh you know
more like venture debt type models where
basically people are
underwriting working capital needs of
say a crypto mining firm
that needs to do capex build out and
they want to borrow in usdc
um because that's the transactional
medium of the crypto economy uh
in some of these cases right so you're
seeing
um kind of more like traditional
borrowing happen
at the institutional level that's
starting to work its way into these loan
books
and i think that will continue i think
our our thesis is that
as usdc in circulation grows
as it becomes more widely accepted as a
payment and settlement medium then lots
of businesses
and individuals are going to want to
borrow it because it's a better
a a better form factor for a dollar than
than what i call ach money or m2 money
as we know it
yeah how big can this get right so
you've gone from about 500 million
dollars to
13.2 billion is this a 100 billion
dollar
opportunity is it a trillion dollar
opportunity how big do you think it can
get
we think it's far larger than a trillion
dollar opportunity
um and and you know our our view is is
really that
if today um in in some ways the total
addressable market for
for something like you know uh a usdc
is in our view it's it's m2
so m2 today globally is about 100
trillion dollars
and so that's commercial bank money
that's convert that's electronic money
in the traditional commercial bank
form factor we believe that
um digital currency form factors are
going to be superior tradition to
traditional commercial bank or ach money
form factors and so over a long period
of time we think that there is a share
shift
um there's a share shift to both
businesses individuals others wanting to
keep
value in in stable coin models
and and so we certainly think it has has
the ability to get into the trillions
um if you look at dollar money markets
today i think they're about five
trillion
so i think there's a lot of ways to look
at that um and this is like
you know digitization of music you know
you know how big was the market for
digital
music uh back when everyone had cds or
or streaming television or you know long
tail
e-commerce markets like amazon or ebay
you know
all these i think are are very very
large
and you just have to pick your time
frame right is this is it a trillion
dollars
in five years is it is it you know five
trillion dollars in ten years
um but i think i think about it as
the share shift that will take place
into this
natively natively form factor of digital
money
uh over over a five to ten year period
it should get to i think
you know ten percent of of of what the
tan might be today
do you feel like uh digital currencies
in general
are simply going to replace uh what you
call ach money
or do you think that they're more market
expanding and kind of the correlator for
those that are listening is essentially
uh uber you could have said hey they're
going to disrupt taxis or you could have
said no they're actually going to expand
the market and
what's going to happen is a lot of
people aren't going to own cars so
they're just going to uber everywhere
and so how do you view that with these
digital currencies versus ach
yeah so i i think um
the way i look at it is is twofold i
think one is
in terms of like the the actual like
money supply
like m1 or n0 right
um we don't really impact that right so
so that is still
sovereign debt basically right that so
so we don't impact that this is just a
form factor on on top of that
do i think that it will be market
expanding yes but in the following way
um just like you know with uh you know i
i used to
use this example like when the web came
about
um i used to make this argument this is
my my first company was tools for
building web applications right that
the net world output of software created
was going to grow exponentially
because it's going to be basically
instantly it's going to be cheap to
basically create to just
distribute software through browsers or
when you know email came out like
the net world output of text-based
communications exploded like
enormously and and so as you've had
basically
open networks that allow you know in in
historical you know terms on the
internet data to flow
instantly for free basically the volume
of activity increased dramatically and
so my view is very similar that
essentially digital currency native
payments infrastructure
over time will drive the cost of
payments to zero
so the ability to sort of charge a fee
to move value or the ability to charge a
business a fee
for them to receive value will approach
zero over time
and as you reduce friction you increase
speed you increase velocity
it's every internet device in the world
connected to this um
and um and you have that kind of speed
and velocity internet
the net world output of payments will
increase exponentially so i actually do
think it's market expanding in terms of
the the volume just overall transaction
volume
in the global economy will increase as a
result of digital currency
that makes sense and i think one of the
the big questions that people don't
understand
uh and asked me to ask is uh
when you think of a digital currency
today you are essentially a private
company who has taken a fiat currency
and you're digitizing it right and
obviously the market wants this you've
grown incredibly fast
uh but now there's a lot of central
banks that are talking about creating
their own digital currencies the idea
would be
uh same monetary policy just this new
technology form factor
and whether it's a digital dollar euro
yen juan you know name your currency
they essentially would end up in what is
a very similar place to where usdc is
today for uh for the digital dollar
do you look at that as uh competition
is that something where there's a
partnership opportunity is that
something where maybe actually the
u.s government central bank treasury et
cetera should just adopt usdc like how
do you see that playing out
uh as they kind of further uh explore
this idea
yeah i mean lots of things to talk about
there
um so just maybe to answer your your
last question first
um we absolutely see opportunities to
partner with national governments around
the world
um and and we believe that you know open
source
open internet technical innovation
public chain
innovation all of the velocity of things
that are happening with that
um combined with you know kind of
technology driven private sector work
is moving at an incredible velocity it's
moving very very fast it's going to move
way faster than government-sponsored r d
initiatives and so
ultimately i do think that leads to a
place where there is real collaboration
but i think to step back though i think
you know
a lot of times people don't really
realize that electronic money
today virtually everywhere in the world
is issued by the private sector
so when you think about um you know
electronic wire money which is the first
form of electronic money
that's issued by commercial banks
central banks sort of
approve this as a as an electronic
medium
but it's run by a consortium of private
companies it's run by a consortium of
private companies in in an organization
called swift
swift is hundreds or thousands of
private sector firms collaborating on
technical standards
and interoperability you take the most
popular form of electronic money that we
have today
which is credit cards and debit cards
that's privately issued electronic money
it is associations consortiums and
private sector actors getting together
to define
standards and interoperability which is
exactly what the card associations
were born to do and it's it's all
privately issued
ach money is the same thing ach networks
are consortium private sector actors
coming up with
common standards for bank to bank
transfer
it's privately issued money um so
the world today is consortium's attack
of open standards or
of of standards at least
interoperability standards and privately
issued models
that's worked pretty well for most of
the world now even in china
where you know there's obviously a lot
of attention on
on the digital yawn um i i think if you
really look closely
there's two things going on one is um
china leapfrog the entire world in
privately issued electronic money in
terms of digital money
alipay and tencent and wechat pay
you know a billion people were using
these as
privately issued electronic money on a
massive scale now in a place like china
that was viewed as too much unchecked
private power and so the development of
the digital yawn is
largely a response to the unchecked
private power
of these very very very large private
institutions and you're seeing that kind
of get reined in in a variety of ways
and so china's a little bit unique in
that
you know the government's largely run by
engineers
and uh and they build stuff like they
build
a lot of things um and that's not really
the model
in most of the western capitalist and
many other markets in the world where
it really is technology innovation
entrepreneurial innovation private
sector actors you know free market
open competitive environments that's
what has allowed innovation to thrive
in in in the capitalist world or at
least the democratic capitalist world
and i think that that will continue to
serve uh
this you know many parts of the world
really really well and so i
you know again coming coming back to the
last question again
i think this creates tremendous
opportunity for consortiums like center
consortium which defines the
self-governance and and and regulatory
and compliance frameworks around usdc
to really grow take on more members more
involvement
etc and so when you think about some of
the recent partnerships i think you guys
have one with visa
a few banks uh is that essentially what
you're trying to do is build these
consortiums so that
uh you can create a lot of the um buy-in
around those standards and that's kind
of the
the viewpoint and direction you're
headed uh or should we think about those
partnerships in a different way
well so our our partnership with visa is
a specific commercial partnership
um aimed at at driving uh
adoption of usdc um in a number of ways
that are kind of compatible with the
existing visa network and
their network of issuers and merchants
um and um and you know i think we're
seeing some really good
uh initial traction with that i think in
general circle
is focused on you know encouraging and
supporting and developing
this broader open ecosystem um you know
the the
the beauty of having something like usdc
be a public protocol
is you don't need to be part of a
consortium to adopt it
thousands of companies have implemented
support for it they don't need to ask
anyone's permission
they can you know build a digital wallet
or they're in exchange in korea or
they're
somewhere in the world they can just
connect to the protocol on a public
blockchain and it just works and so
i think one is just continuing to foster
that that open ecosystem
but yes i i think ultimately you'll see
more partnerships with
established payments companies
established financial institutions banks
others that are going to play an active
role in in this in the development of
this ecosystem
got it let's talk a little bit more
about the treasury product that you guys
have and we'll be rolling out here
a little bit more aggressively to me
that seems like if you can build a
product that
you go to every corporation you say hey
currently you get you know x percent
uh on a monday market fund and there's a
bunch of obstacles and friction
in terms of managing your treasury uh we
can do it better
right better can be a higher rate of
return better can be more
kind of less friction when it comes to
payments whatever it ends up being
talk a little bit about uh why you're so
focused there and kind of what you think
that inflection point can be for circle
and also for the companies that use that
product
absolutely i mean look like stepping
back the way
that we think about this is that
we're gonna go through a period where if
you're a corporation
and you're a corporation that operates
on the internet in some way if you're
like an internet
native company which almost every
company is becoming in some way like
these these sort of internet
leaning corporations you're going to
want to leverage this new financial
infrastructure
you're going to want to leverage because
of its efficiency you're going to want
to leverage it because it allows you to
move money
faster cheaper easier globally or for
with your own customers and you're going
to want to embrace it
as part of your treasury strategy um
you're going to want to store value
in crypto assets like bitcoin you're
going to want to store value
in you know these these forms of of
yield products uh
as well and so i think that just
generally we think over the coming years
tens of thousands of businesses are
going to want to
have you know corporate treasury
accounts with digital currency financial
institutions that
make it easy for them to use this both
as a transactional infrastructure and as
a treasury infrastructure and so we we
think that's a really significant very
large opportunity
and eventually millions of businesses
are going to want to have
accounts and have have access to this
all around the world and so it's it to
us it represents
really a transformation in you know when
you think about
kind of um transaction banking or
treasury services
uh you know global banks like citigroup
or hsbc or or others
um or chase um that provide
accounts for for payments and treasury
right i think um
digital currency native models for that
are ultimately going to become super
attractive
and that's what we're excited about in
the short term i think yeah it's very
specifically
we're in a low yield environment um
digital asset markets
uh have created an opportunity for
high-yield environments and so yes
there's an opportunity to just see
people who want to allocate some of that
static uh unused working capital into
uh whether it be bitcoin or uh or or
or dollarized markets as well we we
think that there'll be continued growth
in that in the in the next year or two
i tend to agree how much of this also
empowers uh something i'm really
interested in which is uh streaming
payments this idea of
lower cost lower friction uh payments
whether that's
you know corporations that say hey we're
gonna completely uh kind of reinvent the
way that we pay our employees maybe we
wanna pay them every day rather than
every two weeks
uh or maybe it's some sort of pay as you
go model i see a lot of people talk
about you know paying as you consume a
podcast or watch a movie or whatever
um how much of uh usdc and the
infrastructure that you're building can
play a part in that
yeah so we're we're really bullish
on like innovations in
in payments and value exchange i think a
huge part of the motivation for this
this goes back eight years to when we
founded circle was this idea of
programmable money
and it captured a lot of people's
imagination
and the idea that you know a dollar
could be like a native data type on the
internet like a jpeg or a music file
and then you could program it and then
you could write code around it um
we are in these super early innings of
that innovation right
d5 protocols themselves are an example
of saying hey i've got a programmable
programmable financial contract well we
are seeing
uh you know smart contracts for
streaming payments there's multiple
projects that have integrated usdc
which allow you to do exactly those
kinds of things like have
metered out payments have you know kind
of buffers and escrows
and have events that trigger you know
you know payments
and payouts i i'm excited very very
excited about
what the kind of open developer
community is going to do now that you
have
smart contract infrastructure and you
can program money in this way
i think we're going to see innovations
in all forms of kind of commerce
relationships
labor relationships trade finance models
invoicing models escrow models like so
many dimensions of
both you know individual to business and
business to business type of
interactions getting mediated by
um you know public chain infrastructure
um streaming payments is a great example
of that
um and it's kind of like the example
earlier you touched on with like an uber
where
you know when when you had like a a
smartphone that had 3g access
and you had a smartphone that had a gps
and you had a smartphone where you could
create
reasonable guise right each one of those
was cool like oh you can actually have a
gui oh it's actually
a reasonable speed on the internet so
you can actually have an app that
performs well
and wow there's this gps but it was the
mash up you put this together someone
kind of said hey if i can match these up
i can revolutionize
you know transportation for for
consumers it's that creativity that
comes up when you have those things and
you can put them together
the same thing's going to happen here
none of us can predict
the breakthrough applications that are
going to be created in this incentivized
social media networks you know
we're seeing this with nfts um and
you're seeing with the social currency
you know kind of model if you have you
know a super efficient micro payment
infrastructure and something like ustc
which you can do now
on you know next-gen chains like solana
and algorand and stuff like that
you you actually can start to build
breakthrough business models so
i'm excited i think that we're going to
see so much there
and i think a lot of times people kind
of you know they they tend to think of
well we already have electronic payments
uh you know isn't this uh this and and
it kind of misses the point right
you know we already had taxis but there
was actually a radical better a 10x
better kind of product that's still
waiting to happen
yeah i tend to think that um a lot of
what
is going to get created hasn't even been
attempted yet and
most most people tend to think uh
somewhat in an evolutionary
uh but yet elementary way right so it's
hey if i know where
we're at point a then point b is kind of
the next thing to think about it's very
hard to kind of see from point a to you
know what's
the uh 26 point away right
so i think that uh i think you're
actually correct there what's next for
circle
as you kind of continue to uh to build
the business obviously uh there's a hope
there's continued uh
kind of adoption and demand for usdc but
what else are you excited about what
else are you working on or what do you
want people to know about
yeah absolutely i mean um there are a
lot of things i
think about the stuff we're working on
so so one is just making sure that the
core
infrastructure for this can be like web
scale
so that you know you can transact
something like usdc
with you know apps that are built for
hundreds of millions of users and you
can transact
in you know in fractions of a second
with extremely low cost so it's just
making sure it's like
i like to call it like moving from dial
up to broadband so we're you know
we're we want to make sure that the like
the fundamental kind of
payment settlement throughput can kind
of move from dial up to broadband sort
of
you know first and second generation
blockchains and then you know sort of
third generation blockchain sort of take
you there
um and so so that's a really big focus
because
that's coming whether it be through nft
apps
global payment companies implementing
this um you know
yeah innovations in social commerce like
all these things are going to
bring a different scale of user base
onto this and so we need to make sure
that it can support that
the the second is you know we're really
trying to build
out this kind of suite of services for
businesses and fintechs that want to
build on this
and so you know what you can expect to
see from circle is
you know more and more kind of
fundamental building blocks for
financial applications um and and
and you know this sort of core you know
we think of it as like this commercial
treasury account type of product and
infrastructure
so more and more from circle to kind of
export uh
support you know not just uh you know
blockchain native firms or crypto
markets companies
but also more and more mainstream
commerce firms
getting into this that's a that's a
really big focus
um and um and you know we also continue
to be super super excited about
you know what we're doing with seed
invest which is extremely fast growing
um and we're helping startups all over
the place raise capital directly on the
internet
larger and larger deals you know the the
crowdfunding exemptions have
expanded considerably and so we have
companies doing 20 million dollar raises
30 million dollar raises as well as
reg c which now allows up to 5 million
raises directly from unaccredited
investors and so
just continuing to help companies raise
capital on the internet
and and obviously we see an opportunity
to weave that more closely with
digital asset infrastructure as well for
sure what keeps you up at night like
when you think about everything you guys
are working on or the industry at large
yeah you know i i think um there's a
there's a few things i mean
you know one is a lot of what i think
about is just like making sure we can
execute there's such a big surface area
of stuff that
we're working on i know every firm in
the crypto space is just like oh my god
we're growing we're growing there's all
this stuff and
just staying staying in front of that
velocity and
coverage area um it's really hard you
know we're
we're we're adding hundreds of new
employees to circle um
you know this year and and you know just
doing that is really really hard
um i think you know i wouldn't say it
keeps me up at night but certainly
because i i generally sleep really well
every night but uh
and i know you do too uh but but uh i
uh i'm religious about sleep as it were
but um
uh you know i think like what's
happening with crypto right now
it's becoming it has reached a different
level of awareness
and it's actually gotten to the point
where
governments are genuinely
you know befuddled afraid
uncertain and you know you're going to
see some stupid decisions get made
and you're just going to see some stupid
decisions get made you're going to see
people make rash decisions
and so i think we really believe
that you know this you know open
financial system
this crypto native economic
infrastructure you know building this
this vision this world is truly better
for the world
it truly delivers more you know uh
opportunities for individuals and
businesses everywhere
um but you know there there's gonna be
this tug and pull
right there's gonna be this tug and pull
of of people wanting to kind of
keep the genie in the bottle wanting the
existing
framework and systems and governance and
other things to kind of be what they
are um and and not really willing to to
embrace the much broader you know
changes that
that crypto involves and i and so i i
think there's just there's a high
threshold i think national governments
are gonna have
more involvement and that puts a lot of
pressure on on the industry
and so that that's something that's
that's significant that that we think
about a lot in and we we just brought on
dante desparte as chief strategy officer
and and head of global policy and he's
he's really spent the last couple of
years
meeting with major government officials
all around the world around these
digital currency issues and so we're
investing
pretty aggressively in policy issues
because we know
that as as this grows as this becomes
more mainstream and it rolls out around
the world
we need to be there you know helping uh
helping make sure
uh that that you know ultimately we're
on the right side of history
so last question for you uh are you
still having fun
i'm having a great time this is awesome
i mean look
you know i've known you for a while and
and um
yeah we got started eight years ago
right and eight years ago
when when we started circle and i told
people i'm i mean i'm creating like a
digital currency bank
uh or whatever people like are you out
of your [ __ ] mind like
like you know and people wouldn't even
talk to me because they thought they
might get in trouble
you know for taking a meeting with
someone who's working on you know
something with bitcoin but
um you know obviously things have
changed a lot
a lot of the ideas that we had you know
i was looking at my series a
deck the other day just for kind of
reminiscing it's like all these ideas
that we had
they're happening now like this is
actually happening
like this so many of these things are
actually happening and you know i knew
that these were going to be these 5 to
10 to 20 year cycles to do this but
i really feel like right now so many of
the things that got so many people
involved in this industry in the first
place are really being realized and so
it's super exciting
it's really really exciting and really
rewarding i asked that question because
i can tell you're having fun which is
uh which is half the battle right that's
what keeps you going yes
yes you have to yeah and anyone who
knows me knows that i i
i tend to be uh a fairly optimistic
person
optimism wins man optimism wins all
right where uh where can we send people
to find you on the internet or
learn more about circle or circles
products if things yeah absolutely so
uh i'm jer alair on twitter
and uh circle.com is uh straight up
where you're gonna find everything you
need about circle
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this jeremy we'll do it
again in the future
awesome thanks palm